money is a sensitive topic but we need
to talk about it because over budget is
over budget as Architects we need to be
mindful and proactive in our practice to
provide value to our clients that's why
today we're going full nerd and talking
spreadsheets I know I know you're about
to click off spreadsheets
boring but just hold up one minute over
the past decade I've perfected this
Excel document and I'm about to share
industry-leading secrets completely for
free do you really want to miss out on
that it's time to walk you through this
architectural project tracker
spreadsheet and show you exactly what
you need to know to be able to replicate
this in your own practice or download it
down below so let's get started down the
bottom we have a series of tabs each one
with their own unique purpose the cheat
sheet provides some instructions at the
top which basically indicate to you
everything I'm about to say in this
video but in text reference so in case
you miss it you can refer back to there
the cheat sheet is designed so you can
come in here and populate all of this
red text so that it pre-populates
everything else throughout the
spreadsheet there's project details
client details Builder details and of
course the architect's details all of
this is valuable information that you
can quickly reference later on in the
project so just go through update all of
the red text input your information and
you're ready to go you notice that one
element is highlighted in Black the
Builder total price SLC contract value
that is automatically populated from the
Builder's quote down the bottom which
we'll get to in a minute now this is
where I found the most value in having
this cheat sheet rather than going
through multiple Pages trying to find
the correct information inputting it
every time you can come in once populate
it once and it would do the rest for you
all of the formulas have been set up so
it makes life so much easier and it
speeds up the whole process the cover
page is of course my generic cover page
if you wish to replace it with your own
feel free it is there as a placeholder
the project details has been outlined in
the tab down below as Auto because all
of this is automatically populated from
our cheat sheet so if we select one of
these items you'll see it is referencing
the cheat sheet
g28 and of course cheat sheet g28 is our
project address so everything has been
automatically linked which means you can
come in once detail it move on at the
bottom we have an automatic date tracker
this document transmittal date is
intended as a print date so if you print
and distribute this entire package to
the client to the Builder to whomever
you have a date specifically in this
section so that everybody knows when it
was timestamped now each of these
sections has everything I have found
valuable and requ required in the
project on all sorts of different
contracts there may be additional things
for different services and additional
things for different countries but
generally I found most of it for
Australian work is here of course make
sure you go through this in full detail
and add anything you need for your own
personal spaces everything in the black
celles is a title or automatically
populated everything running in the gray
and white format generally is something
that you need to fill in unless it has
Auto written on it so in this instance
it's all pre-populated you don't have to
worry about it this page is completely
done ready to go the Builder's quote is
something that I recommend you forward
to the Builder to fill in during tender
if they fill this out during tender it's
going to make your life so much easier
because you're going to have all of
these numbers
prepopulated I've broken down the
descriptions into the most common
construction descriptions that Builders
will generally provide there's going to
be many many different projects out
there and so many things that you can't
put into one template so of course
there's a few extra rows that you're
allowed to populate your own items in
and you can delete whatever you need and
replace it however you need for your
specific project in this instance all
you need to do is come in and place a
cost so let's say the preliminaries on
this project are $50,000 excluding taxes
then the Builder's margin is 20% that's
automatically populated from that cheat
sheet which means even though it costs
them $50,000 for their preliminaries
they're going to charge you another 20%
on top so overall it's going to cost you
$60,000 for that line item plus GST at
the bottom so just that line item could
be
$66,000 there are some totals and totals
at the bottom which are of course
automatically populated and again all
we're really filling out is this section
here in the spreadsheet I can revert
that back to zero and it automatically
populates back to zero at the end end of
this video we will go through a
completed example to show you exactly
how this could look like at the end of a
project of course when a builder price
is something they can't predict
everything under the sun sometimes there
are variations sometimes there are
changes to the Project true untrue
Justified unjustified they need to be
added into our project and our budget in
this instance there is no variations I
haven't placed any examples in but we
could simply type in change of door
and window and then we have our status
appear if we don't include our status
and say let's say that was a $1,500
change we'll see the Builder margin for
variations is a little bit higher
because of our cheat sheet it's going to
cost $375 for the margin but the
approved subtotal is still zero that's
because we haven't updated our status we
haven't approved that variation if the
variation isn't approved if it's
rejected or if it's pending it doesn't
affect the budget so the the second we
hit approve it automatically updates our
approved total but if we change that to
rejected it strikes it back out at zero
the Builder has provided the price we
know what the price is but we've moved
on from that item and we don't need to
worry about it so let's change
everything back to zero and move on to
the next section the variations is very
similar to Builder quote set up in
exactly the same way progress claims is
where it gets a little bit more
intricate and where you have to put your
time and effort in the course of the
project the Builder will start claiming
for the work that they've done depending
on the project it could be five stages
for a general architectural home
completion if it's through the bank if
it's a custom clone and it's paid by
cash it could be nine claims it could be
900 claims but generally I found that
nine claims is more than enough for a
residential home all of the fields in
Black are automatically populated and
they take it back to the builders quote
so you don't have to come back in here
and update everything every every single
time it's automatically there so if you
come into the Builder quote and add
random item we can then go to our
progress claim and see random item has
been included
automatically when the Builder provides
their progress claim generally you ask
them to break it down with the reference
numbers attached next to them so if
they're claiming $50,000 for their
preliminaries they will tell you $50,000
against reference one so you can then
come in type in $50,000 and the rest
will be done for you taking the time to
input all of this data each progress
claim is going to make life super simple
to track this throughout the entire
course of the construction period what
you see is $50,000 is automatically
populated in claim one and we have a
series of different subtotals we have
our per claim
subtotal which is this whole row here
and black out is the subtotal for the
Builder's total so as the Builder price
increases this black area inas increases
as well what we also have which isn't
common in these spreadsheets is a
running per claim subtotal so claim one
plus claim 2 is currently still
$55,000 but if we add another $55,000
claim here then claim one and two goes
to $60,500 and claim one was still
$55,000 so we know how much we've spent
to to dat in total obviously that works
1 2 3 4 5 it's pretty self-explanatory
so don't need to go through that too
much more the second page is a
continuation of the first all of this is
a replica of the first page again you
don't need to touch it and same sort of
system claims 6 through to n what we
have here as well is the claimed to date
the percentage that we've claimed from
the entire builders quote so let's walk
through an example let's say the
demolition was
$2,000 and we come back to our progress
claim you'll see demo demolition
including the Builder's margin is
$2,400 and let's say the Builder has
charged us $1,200 in claim six that
means 50% of the demolition has been
claimed for this I found to be an
extremely helpful way to assess actual
progress claims so when you're on site
you go the build has claimed $1,200 of
demolition is there half a house still
left sweet 50% that seems like a fair
and reasonable amount have they knocked
the whole house they've under claimed Mr
a builder Mrs Builder please increase
your claim to 100% that whole thing's
gone or potentially that whole house is
still there and they shouldn't be
claiming a single scent this is a very
very obvious and easy way to understand
how much work has been done based on the
amount that they've claimed once
everything is populated of course the
total number in the bottom right hand
corner will be the total percentage
completed today so because we only have
2,600 down the bottom we have 50% total
but if we were to introduce an extra
figure here in glazing let's say
$50,000 come back to our progress claim
we'd see the builders only claim 2% of
their total quote which also allows us
to cash flow and understand what is
coming up moving on to variation claims
once again same sort of concept the Vos
are automatically populated from your
variations tab down the bottom here so
anything you type will automatically be
introduced into the variation claim if
it's rejected it won't show up in your
approved Vos same as before you need to
include your per claim for the
variations you can individually place
every item in and everything is
replicated exactly the same as what it
was for the progress claim except
specifically for variations and finally
in this spreadsheet we have our
Securities and our summaries this page
is automatically populated except for
this final row here this you have to
come into and select the drop- down menu
to be able to say what the payment
status is of that progress claim has it
been reviewed has it been accepted is it
rejected has it been paid or is it
overdue so generally we go accepted
we've sent out our project certificates
the client is ready to pay or the bank
is ready to transfer the funds and then
once we've been advised that it's been
paid we simply change it to paid and we
can move on to the next stage of the
process the areas here in Black once
again they're populated from our cheat
sheet and the rest is all automatically
populated as well so all the formulas
have been preset ready to go fine-tuned
and really created so it is super super
simple anybody can understand if they're
following along so now let's look at a
completed example if we close that we
have our completed example open in front
of us let's move back to our cheat sheet
which I've left exactly the same as the
template the cover page exactly the same
the project details automatically
populated exactly the same the build is
quote is where it starts to actually
change and make a little bit more sense
this information has been populated
based on project and showcases exactly
how much each preliminary item may have
cost the Builder has provided all of
these items which has resulted in a $1.6
million project almost
1.7 that means if we come back to our
cheat sheet you'll see that same number
is automatically populated back to where
the progress claim was so we don't have
to double up at all throughout this
project there's been a couple variations
now you'll see sometimes you have
credits as well as variations in this
instance the client decided to supply
their own white goods and appliances
which there was an allowance of
$50,000 Plus+ in the original Builder
estimate so in the variation they have
50,000 and they're good to go and a few
things have changed some were rejected
so they resulted in a z0 but most are
approved so overall there was only about
$6,000 of variations approved very very
small in the grand scheme of things
considering it's a $1.7 million project
moving on to progress claims you'll see
that it is data that is populated and
numbers are just everywhere but as you
work through it Claim by Claim by claim
month by month by month it makes a lot
more sense than just looking at it
overwhelmingly in one instance but what
it does provide is an overall holistic
example how the project has gone so
understanding that we've come to claim 9
and we finished claim 9 we can see that
everything has been claimed 100% there's
been no over claims there's been no
under claims everybody should be happy
in this process we know that the whole
project has been finished 100% on budget
to the original builders quote now of
course things have changed and there
have been variations so we have the same
approach for the
variations everything has been claimed
100% overall we've claimed 100% of our
variation
register and each variation has been
accounted for last but not least is of
course our summaries and our Securities
page if we go through this in a little
bit of detail to try to understand and
explain all of this each progress claim
has been broken down here our subtotal
excluding GST for each claim and GST
every country has a different name for
GST could be vat in Europe so you can
change the GST to whatever you need it
to be and of course that is
automatically populated from that cheat
sheet so if your vat or your GST is not
10% instead of going through and
updating every single formula possible
you can just change that to 11 12 15 8%
whatever your taxes are and it will
automatically populate that that way we
know progress claim 1 was 18,000 then
100 150 and so forth we know how much
each claim was and how much it cost
overall we also know how much a project
cost the same goes for the variations we
know how much was charge per variation
and where our credits lie we also know
the total figure so finally we have our
actual contract subtotal which sums both
of our progress claim and our variation
data because at the end of the day we
didn't spend 1.68 3 we spent an extra
$6,000 so we spent 1.68 n that figure
could be another million do half million
it could be whatever there variations to
the contract so the contract price and
the final figure the client is paid is
different now in instances here in
Australia there are cash retentions or
unconditional Bank guarantees in this
instance it's a cash retention per claim
excluding variations so there's 5% cash
retention claimed on every single claim
which means 5% of claim 1 through the N
is held in escrow and 50% of that is
returned once the Builder completes the
project the other 50% is returned at the
end of the defect liability period which
on our cheat sheet indicates is 12
months so during the project $84,000 of
payment is withheld from the Builder as
a security 42,000 of that is returned
once the architect deems practical
completion has been reached and the
project has been completed and the other
42,000 is returned at the end of defects
this provides a form of security if
anything goes wrong throughout that
first 12 months as an example let's say
a box got a leaks there's some
structural cracking and the Builder just
outright refuses to come and fix them
the client has some sort of comfort some
sort of security to go I need to fix
this out of this pool of money and it's
already sitting there as a security it's
very rare that happens but obviously
forms security and high value contracts
are incredibly important because if
anything does go wrong or if a pandemic
happens again and Builders go randomly
bust we have some sort of safety net now
last but not least Le is of course the
payment due so even though our progress
claim one was
$185,000 we have to minus our cash
retention which then makes the invoice
from the Builder
$175,000 not
$185,000 and all of these items have
been paid the project has been completed
so this8 tab Excel spreadsheet is
basically a decade worth of knowledge
and experience if you want to go ahead
and download it it is available to
purchase in the link down below save
yourself a ton of time trust me it is
worth the money you don't really want to
spend hours replicating this but you're
more than welcome to either way I'm just
hoping that this is going to be able to
provide you with some more clarity some
more insight and help keep your projects
on budget throughout the entire project
anyway that's all from me team my name's
David Tomic I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did hit the Subscribe button and
the notification Bell for more weekly
content